[Música]
hola
yo no estoy bien o mejor digo muy buenas
y nicotina bueno algunos conocieron este
saludo no
digan lo conocen vamos buenos chicos
esta vez una charla es algo serio así
que disculpe si no me ven en modo
personaje a red pero nada yo quería
hablar un poco de vino para esta charla
te da la chance de ponerte en la piel
más de uno mismo no más de lo que sentís
viste sé que tal vez a mucha gente no le
importa pero a otra tal vez sí porque
quiere tener no sé alguno de ustedes a
una vez pensó la idea de hacer vídeos en
youtube
cuantos
son muchos sí si son como 50
bueno les debes empezar a decir un poco
como yo arranque
trump y betty boop tranca colegio
videojuego todo el día la play encerrado
en mi caso no sé si habrá alguno así
como shop en ser encerrado en mi casa de
todo el día jugando a la play y unam y
una vez me dice que me compré una cámara
vamos a hacer vídeos y yo como
he hecho amigos - vídeo tengo pero
realmente me copé o sea me copé y fue
momento largo d
editar boludo ahí está la clave el
trabajo el trabajo duro son me he
quedado hasta 7 8 de la mañana editando
vídeos tipo para que salgan a la
perfección tipo hasta una miniatura son
lo que son las miniaturas no de los
vídeos las que aparece el tipo
todo esto así hay que editar hay que
meterle esfuerzo guacho es una banda y
nada así a medida empecé a editar editar
vídeos a subir vídeos a youtube a una
solo estará suscrito para hay unos
suscritos
a los amores
así que nada empecé a subir vídeos ahí a
meterle constante constante y no hice
colaboraciones grandes para mí o sea en
lo personal si conocen algún nombre
digan
pedrito m
de mente pero que está por ahí igual
y si colaboraciones que para mí me
fortalecieron mucho
están buscando todos
y na
vas creando vínculos es muy bueno
conoces gente nuevas conoces lugares
nuevos eso es hermoso en la vida no sé
seguro piensan en viajar y es lo más
lindo que hay conocer gente nueva
conocer gente de youtube y lo más lindo
pero pero
todo tiene sus consecuencias siempre
tienes que ver que la gente puede decir
lo que quieras de voz
yo les voy a contar un ejemplo muy
rápido rápido rápido rápido y rápido un
ejemplo que me pasó el otro día fue como
en una pizzería no fue con la presencia
está con la pizza en la boca así y un
niño metió una foto normal me parece que
la pizza
viene la madre del niño me dice
flaco
la foto salió mal y no sé si sale mal la
foto me dice así otra bueno
me dice me dice sé lo que me dice esto
que pasa flaco por ser famoso me dice
aguanta gran seriedad y anda
y uno tiene que aceptar dispositiva
decide no le puedo decir nada entender y
así miles de ejemplos tipo me habrán
tocado el timbre de tipo 5 en la mañana
muy buenas muy muy buenas al timbre tipo
5 a la mañana puedes esperar mucho de la
gente pero que no lo hacen con mala
intención pero son cosas que a uno le
pasan cuando elegís este camino así que
si ustedes quieren empezar en youtube en
la plataforma empezar a hacer vídeos
métanle osea si lo que le gusta al
principio siempre va a haber gente que
les va a decir no que onda 6 vídeos y
una foto que subiste es lo más normal
hagas lo que hagas siempre te van a
criticar no hablan en serio en serio y
vos hagas lo que hagas guacho o sea a
una vez le pasó a una es lo criticaron
ustedes por algo y por los hate yaron
hagas lo que hagas te van a agitar pero
cosas que tiene que hacer guacho mételes
métele bueno listo no escuches y seguí
se iba hecho cosa no quiero hacer la
típica charla motivacional no tipo
compre tus sueños sigue lo que deseas
pero es realidad boludo porque si no lo
hacéis por vos no lo va a hacer nadie
entendés
nadie lo va a hacer vos tenés que poner
esa semilla trabajarla y fortalecerla
nada es que nadie lejía que no pueden
guacho sigan sus sueños
muchas gracias por haber venido un gusto
amigos nos vemos